there's two major things folks that we
find with the millionaires that we've
studied that cause them to become
millionaires one is steadily investing
in retirement and good mutual funds
401ks IRAs all right steadily overtime
investing the second thing is a paid for
house
those two are the biggest two elements
that we see cause people to be a
millionaire the typical millionaire we
studied was 51 years old they had like a
million and a half to two million dollar
net worth let's say they had a million
and a half dollar net worth in our case
study uh that you we usually would find
they had like a half a million 600 000
paid for house and then they had like
seven eight hundred nine hundred
thousand dollars in their 401 case
um and so that's generally how we saw
them getting there in that first one to
five million dollars worth of net worth
those are two big things